i
[Música]
ah
brasil es el peor país del mundo en el
manejo de la crisis sanitaria causada
por el coronavirus según el instituto
lówy de sídney australia que analizó la
actuación de 98 países en el mundo este
próximo resultado según el instituto se
debe a jair bolsonaro el presidente de
brasil que desde el primer momento
minimizó el impacto en la gravedad del
virus y que desoyó las recomendaciones
de la organización mundial de la salud
el resultado es que el país más grande
de américa latina ya superó las 225 mil
muertes por el commit y además tiene más
de 9 millones de casos lo más grave es
que en este momento hay una cepa
amazónica que ha causado un colapso
sanitario en la ciudad de manaus y el ex
ministro de sanidad luis enrique mande
está advierte que los próximos 60 días
son cruciales porque esa cepa ya está
circulando por todo brasil y podría
causar una enorme pandemia dentro de la
pandemia
[Música]
solo superado por brasil méxico es el
segundo país con el peor manejo de la
pandemia de kobe 19 de acuerdo con un
estudio del instituto lówy de australia
el reporte evalúa las políticas públicas
contra el coronavirus en un listado de
98 países en el que méxico se ubica en
la posición 97 se trata del segundo
estudio internacional reciente que pone
a méxico por los suelos esto luego del
reporte de la agencia bloomberg que
considera méxico el peor lugar para
estar durante la pandemia en una lista
de 53 naciones estudiadas uno de los
factores utilizados en la investigación
de bloomberg es el índice de letalidad
que en méxico es del 7.5 por ciento el
presidente lópez obrador suele rechazar
este tipo de estudios al asegurar que
solo buscan dañar la imagen de méxico en
el mundo lo cierto es que el país
acumula ya más de 158 mil muertos y es
el tercer lugar mundial en cuanto al
número de muertos por colon habidos
[Música]
con más de 21 millones de contagios de
kobe 19 colombia según un análisis del
instituto australiano lo we es la
tercera nación del mundo que peor ha
manejado la pandemia el país andino
detectó su primer caso de coronavirus el
6 de marzo de 2020 e impuso una de las
cuarentenas más largas y estrictas de
latinoamérica que dejó patente las
diferencias entre el ejecutivo de
manduca y los gobiernos locales por la
estrategia para contener el virus sin
embargo debido a las fuertes
desigualdades sociales que padece el
país y pese a las constantes
restricciones a la movilidad de sus
ciudadanos
colombia está sumida en una virulenta
segunda ola y ya ha detectado tres casos
de la variante brasileña las autoridades
colombianas están siendo fuertemente
criticadas por la gestión de la
vacunación pero el gobierno le resta
credibilidad a este tipo de estudios
mientras tanto los colombianos ven con
recelo como países de la región que han
comenzado a inocular a sus poblaciones y
pese a superar los 52 mil decesos el
país todavía no ha comenzado el proceso
de inmunización que según tú que
iniciara el 20 de febrero
[Música]